♪♪
-Welcome to "Summer
Corrections," you guys.
You can't bedazzle handcuffs.
A BeDazzler punches
through fabric, not metal.
So if you were...
off to prison
and that was the one thing
you were looking forward to...
yet another parade
a jackal has rained on.
[ Laughter ]
We showed a picture
of Abraham Lincoln in a fedora.
We said it was a fedora.
We were told it was a trilby...
also that Lincoln could
not have worn a fedora
because the style did not
come into fashion until 1883,
when French actress
Sarah Bernhardt
wore one in a play
called "Fédora."
This is all helpful
for you to know
if you're ever looking
for a fun conversation ender.
[ Laughter ]
"You guys talking about hats?"
"Ugh, Gary."
I said that Koozie was
a portmanteau of beer and cozy.
I misspoke, of course.
It is a portmanteau
of cool and cozy.
Beer plays no part in it.
Of course,
a part of a portmanteau
is known as "apartmanteau."
My favorite portmanteau
involving the word beer
is the word for when you have
a beer with your fiancée,
which is, of course,
Kelly Rowland.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, guys. "Avatar" takes place
on a moon, not a planet.
I said it was a planet.
It's a moon.
And if you remember from the
film, to get to that moon,
you have to enter a cryosleep
because the trip is so long.
And if you want to know
how long,
in order to get there,
it takes almost
as long as it takes
to make "Avatar 2."
[ Laughter ]
What is the hold up with
"Avatar"?
I mean, what little Na'vi I know
I'm going to forget.
[ Laughter ]
The moon's name is Pandora.
And it's very hard place.
It's an almost unlivable
place for humans...
because it's Pandora with ads.
[ Laughter ]
My in-laws have Pandora
with ads.
[ Laughter ]
One of the many draws.
[ Exhales sharply ]
We mentioned that Sidney Powell
chugging -- excuse me --
a Diet Dr Pepper during her
January 6th testimony was bad...
bad brand recognition for
Diet Dr Pepper.
Our joke was it was almost
as bad as that time
Mussolini was pictured
drinking a Fanta.
And, well, we heard a lot
from you guys
about the history of Fanta.
And if you're a big fan,
don't run to the Wikipedia page.
Let's just say Fanta's history
has a German element.
[ Laughter ]
Which is never --
If you're a fan
of the genealogy shows,
it's never good when
a German element pops up.
When Skip Gates said,
"Now, your grandparents
were from Buenos Aires,
but did you know
they moved there from Berlin?"
[ Laughter ]
Fanta originated in 1940
in Germany
due to the American trade
embargo against Nazi Germany.
They had to find a replacement.
You know, because no matter what
you think about World War Two
and the different sides and
I don't want to relitigate it...
[ Laughter ]
...everybody loves soda pop.
[ Chuckles ]
Um...
This made me laugh a lot
because this is all
on the Wikipedia page.
You know, so now we've
established the Fanta history.
In February 2015, a 75th
anniversary version of Fanta
was released in Germany
packaged in glass bottles.
An associated television
ad referenced
the history of the drink
and said the Coca-Cola Company
wanted to bring back "the
feeling of the good old times,"
which was interpreted
by many to mean Nazi rule.
The ad was subsequently
replaced.
[ Laughter ]
"Klaus!
Klaus, get in here!"
[ German accent ]
"Based on your tone,
you've see the new ad."
[ Normal voice ] "Klaus!"
But people still like Fanta.
We got to --
Look, some stuff
came out of Nazi Germany
that had upside, right?
VW cars. Fanta.
US space program.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I also was told
I'm pronouncing Fanta wrong.
It's "Fahnta."
So to whoever was offended
by my pronunciation,
apologies, mein fuhrer.
[ Laughter ]
This is a tran-- So again,
we just had a two-week hiatus.
I spent it with my kids.
Lovely time with my kids.
And you'll see why
this is a transition,
because if I'm doing
any corrections
over the last two weeks,
it's to children, right,
things they get incorrect.
And your job as a parent,
to correct them.
So this is a --
this is a true story
and a true thing
that my son said.
We were talking about the fact
that -- this was to
our six-year-old Ashe --
how lucky he is that he knows
all four of his grandparents
and how his grandmother never
met any of her grandparents.
My wife's mother, her family,
her parents were
Holocaust survivors.
This is a true story.
So we were telling this
to my son, and he's curious.
You know, he's a six-year-old,
so he's curious and he's said,
"How did her grandparents die?"
And my wife said,
"Well, they actually all died
at the same time during a war."
And he said,
"Were they soldiers?"
And my wife, very deftly,
I think, said,
"Not all people who die in a war
are soldiers."
And then my six-year-old said,
"Um, were they drummers?"
[ Laughter ]
I guess the question is
is it okay
when kids are too young
to talk about the Holocaust yet,
do you go,
"Yeah, they were drummers"?
Rabies.
There were some different
takes on rabies.
We talked about rabies.
Someone wrote,
"When I was eight years old" --
We talked about whether or not
you can test for rabies.
And someone wrote,
"When I was eight years old,
I had to get shots for rabies
due to being bitten
multiple times by mice
my sister and I had found
in a sack of grain.
14 shots, one every day
for two weeks, in the stomach."
That is awful and I'm sorry
you had to go through that
as an eight-year-old.
How do you get bitten
multiple times by the mice?
At some point, you just got
to get your hand
out of the sack, right?
I mean, I get it.
I mean,
if I, as an eight-year-old,
came across a sack of grain,
I'd be pretty excited, too.
[ Laughter ]
But at some point,
you got to just
let the mice have their grain.
But then somebody else said --
hold on real quick --
there is -- True, there is...
Wait. Hold on.
Oh, I said you had to cut off
the head to test for rabies.
And someone said,
"Cutting off the head
and sending it out to get tested
is an outdated method
of rabies detection."
Nowadays, tests are performed on
samples of saliva serum,
spinal fluid, and skin
biopsies of hair follicles
at the nape of the neck."
So it's outdated
to cut off the head.
So if you ever are getting
tested for rabies
and your doctor describes
himself as old-fashioned,
run!
[ Laughter ]
We had two jokes
in "Surprise Inspection"
that I did not name
the writer of.
They were both Scollins'.
[ Laughter ]
One was a lawyer
who exposed himself,
referred to his genitals
as Exhibit D,
and the other was about
Mac Tonight --
the the moon-headed
McDonald's mascot...
doing cocaine.
If you're ever on the --
if I ever don't mention it,
it might be Scollins.
Mac Tonight,
very much a...like Fanta,
developed by Pol Pot...
[ Laughter ]
Early -- An early mascot
for the Khmer Rouge.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, somebody wrote,
"Hey, Seth has Wally" --
cue-card Wally -- "has Wally
considered becoming an actor?
His face is very expressive."
Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
"Corrections" is --
Again, this isn't a place
to brag or toot our own horn,
but it is Emmy-nominated
for its second time
and against some very fine
competition once again --
defending champ
"Carpool Karaoke,"
"Randy Rainbow"...
...Stephen Colbert's
"Tuning Out the News,"
and "I Think You Should Leave"
with our friend Tim Robinson.
So wonderful -- I don't know
who I'm gonna vote for...
but I'm going to use this time
in between rounds
to watch them all.
And I will, at some point,
politic,
but not necessarily for this
if I don't feel like
it's the best one.
Because who am I
if I just throw away my vote?
We mentioned
Henry Wadsworth Longfellow
and his poem
"Paul Revere's Ride"
and how that poem
is historically inaccurate.
And somebody wrote this --
I could not verify
this fact about
Henry Wadsworth Longfellow,
but somebody wrote that he wrote
the midnight ride of Paul Revere
for the most noble of reasons --
a girl.
He was wooing, a girl whose aunt
was a Paul Revere descendant
and super into
that part of her identity.
And the story goes
Longfellow wrote the poem
to get in her good graces
so he could get
with the niece.
And if that's true, Henry,
I hope you got your Wadsworth.
[ Laughter ]
We have fun.
Oh.
The mugs.
I got an update today
on the mugs.
I got some very exciting news
about the mugs...
and I was told I could make
a very exciting announcement
about the mugs.
And then right
before I came out,
someone ran up to me and said,
"Don't say anything
about the mugs!"
But I think it's pretty close,
you guys.
And here's the thing.
I need to remind you again --
we got to move the mugs.
We got to move the mugs
'cause I made some promises to
the merch people about the mugs.
And I'm realizing after having
talked to some of my friends
who went to business school
that I made a mistake,
'cause they said, "How many mugs
do you think we'll need?"
and I said, "I don't know.
About 300,000 people
watch an episode
of 'Corrections' each week."
And they said, "How many do you
think will buy mugs?"
And I said, "Half?"
That might be high, guys.
[ Laughter ]
So, like, maybe just get one for
you and get one for a friend?
Anyway, tune in next week for
a hopefully exciting mug news,
and we'll see you for yet
another "Summer Corrections."